r ce concert cette organisation pour moi
il ne fait nul doute qu'il y à une
atteinte à l'ordre public et que dès
lors normalement ce concert devrait être
annulé alors nous allons poser la
question de la déprogrammation de ce
concert elle est posée depuis ce matin
aux internautes du figaro c'est la
question du jour sur lefigaro.fr il y a
eu près de douze mille votants rappelle
que ça n'est pas un sondage puisque vote
qui veut sur notre site internet et 85 %
des voitures sont favorables à
l'interdiction du concert du rappeur
médine
est-ce aussi votre avis edouard tétreau
faut-il déprogrammer ce concert ça se
dit quand même qu'il est une sagesse
populaire une sagesse républicaine c'est
un sujet dire que vous la partagez
oui c'est un sujet lourd c'est nous
vivons dans un pays si thomas au mois
on écrit un texte et vont chanter une
chanson pour dire mort aux juifs sales
arabes des noirs à la mer on va en
prison et c'est très bien
si en revanche on dit crucifiant les
laker comme à golgotha on dit je me suis
fidèle la marianne est une femelle
tatoué fuck god sur les mamelles si
j'applique la charia les voleurs
pourront ne pourront plus faire de main
courante etc
je mets des fatwas sur la tête des cons
enfin j'en passe et des meilleurs la pa
touche parce que si on dit quelque chose
ou attention c'est de l'islamophobie
il faut savoir où on est exactement soit
nous sommes en république et dont et des
droits de l'homme et dans ces cas-là ce
monsieur non seulement ne peut
évidemment pas être programmé au
bataclan
mais il faut aller le chercher sur les
incitations à la haine qui sont contenus
dans cet ex dans ses expressions
il faut aussi noter ça je reconnais bien
là un double langage vicieux qui est qui
est très dangereux qui fait son oeuvre
aujourd'hui malheureusement dans le pays
c'est c'est le disent et ils essaient de
se justifier dans une émission et tout
cela c'est normal j'ai tendu un piège
est tendu un piège pour que les gens qui
caricaturent l'islam etc
il faut être si on croit comme thomas le
croire si on croit que la france est
encore le pays des droits de l'homme
si on croit que la france est encore une
république dans laquelle nous pouvons
vivre avec un vivre ensemble on met des
mots que l'on souhaite alors il faut
agir
monsieur comme ils s'appellent médine
n'est rien d'autre qu'un dieudonné
d'extrême gauche extrêmement dangereux
je crois que nous avons été beaucoup
trop timide complaisant face à ce type
d'expression d'appel
allen la violence et qu'il est temps de
reconquérir le terrain quand j'écoute
une députée de la république dira je
vois pas où est le problème daniel aux
gones dans quel pays habite dans quel
pays sommes nous sommes plus en
république on n'est pas non plus grâce
iomega si la france l'avait dit avant
ayant récemment 80 depuis hier qu'avait
comme il est supporter on n'est pas
tombé dans les panneaux en fait que le
15 août la très chic on époque j'étais
tombé très bas mais je dirais moi c'est
l'autre ou pas ces maps et pardon est ce
qu'on peut dire indifféremment
crucifiant les ics mort aux juifs sales
arabes les noirs à la mer ou alors on ne
peut pas le dire si on ne peut pas le
dire au nom de vivre ensemble en paix et
dans un pays républicain
alors il faut agir il est là
l'indulgence la complaisance de certains
et notamment de certains partis face à
ce mouvement
ces appels allen s'est ralentie
république ça c'est parler vous me
parlez vous parlez de l'indulgence en
fait des dirigeants du bataclan qui ont
pris la responsabilité si un jour elle
mettre dans un débat non mais pas en
fait je vous réponds toujours ça des
producteurs c'est moi qui ressemble à
vrai dire le couple avait dans ma sphère
du double langage à la médine pour dire
je leur ai tendu un piège à fait vous ne
l'avez pas laisser parler ne m'avait pas
laissée par les noms je suis en
désaccord
voilà je suis en désaccord vorey profond
avec vous parlez vous en faites de
l'indulgence des programmateurs du
bataclan mm et moi je vous parle de sa
ronde à m'en parlez vous de l'indulgence
laval et vannes où est ce qu'on a le
droit de dire que je marque opi mort aux
juifs comme arabes match aussi mauvais
nombre baisser le nombre
puis-je être en désaccord avec vous
exprimer mon point de vue
quelque chose et je suis confus de avec
un désaccord en fait c'est mon appareil
symbian
les producteurs du bataclan n'ont vu
aucune difficulté à programmer médine
deuxième chose l'association des
victimes du bataclan a pris exactement
la même position
au final nous apportions des familles
qui sont légitimes et plus légitime
non juste dire maman vous n'en avez vous
n'en faites pas trop nous avons je crois
vraiment écouter vos arguments on est
qu'on écoute ceux de mathieu sous caire
j'ajoute simplement qu' il ya deux
avocats qui sur lefigaro.fr occurrence
sur donc sur son site internet
avocat des familles eux disent il
faudrait mais je me fie à ce que dit
l'association sa question et encore une
fois les programmateurs du matin clan
qui sont totalement insensé mais s'il
vous plaît je constate que la terrine et
matthew je constate que la polémique a
été initiée par la droite et par
l'extrême droite et par la droite
extrême et que depuis je ne suis pas un
fanatique de monsieur médine que je ne
connais pas c'est un rapport que je ne
connais pas que je n'écoute pas ce que
j'ai découvert ces textes
j'ai découvert ce texte gg néanmoins
noté qu'il avait lui même chercher à
mettre de l'eau dans son vin depuis des
paroles que vous citez qui remonte à
donc vous ne verrez pas pour faire court
film mais je suis bien sûr je ne suis
indulgent vis-à-vis de rien enfin
personne ne conteste le fait que le
l'islamisme radical est un danger pour
la waeslandienne mal à prendre position
sur le fond j'ai aucun problème
j'entends en fait comme vous vous
déprogrammée par je faire court je pense
que disent les encore une fois les
responsables du bataclan et
l'association qui défend la mémoire des
victimes se retranchait derrière le
monde
je le retrouve l'expression j'ai lancé
sans mandat de quel droit est ce que
maintenant c'est moi qui reprend la
parole merci beaucoup car je suis
l'animateur de ce débat et je vous
remercie beaucoup d'y participer et donc
thomas guénolé je vous passe la parole
je suis fan de rap il ya plusieurs
morceaux de médine que j'aime bien par
exemple la chanson protest-song j'aime
beaucoup
ou alors une chanson qu'il a chanté avec
deux autres rappeurs qui s'appelle kery
james et youssoupha qui s'appelle contre
nous c'est une chanson que j'aime
beaucoup et pas celle là un rythme lent
mais je dis juste que par rapport à
d'autres intervenants il se trouve que
est un fan de rappel ayant par ailleurs
étudié pour un de mes bouquins en
l'occurrence un bouquin consacré au
thème de la diabolisation des jeunes de
banlieue en fait je connais bien le
sujet du rap conscient c'est des choses
que j'ai beaucoup écouté beaucoup lui
peut-être que ça me permet d'avoir une
certaine distance sur ces sujets là
c'est à dire que je voudrais rappeler
que dans le rap
l'agressivité est une est une figure de
style ce n'est pas du premier degré je
vous prends un exemple le rappeur
sociale le rappeur sofiane quand il fait
des chansons où il décrit sa vie de
gangster qui tuent des gens et qui fait
des grands trafics
il faut pas prendre ça au premier de
nomalys et fiable attendez je vais je
suis finir sofiane il n'est pas vraiment
gangster veille par contre si vous
écoutez ses chansons au premier degré il
est en train de vous dire qu'il va
descendre tout le quartier pour pouvoir
plus de vue de faire plus de business
voilà donc encore une fois la différence
entre un artiste et quelqu'un qui est
dans le jeu ne sais quelle démarche
politique c'est précisément que ont il
s'agit d'une expression artistique
en parlant de ça d'ailleurs moi j'ai une
position de principe qui est de dire non
à la censure de l'expression artistique
on a beaucoup évoqué je suis charlie
dans le contexte actuel je voudrais
rappeler qu'un élément central de je
suis charlie c'est de considérer qu'on
doit préserver la liberté d'expression
en particulier la provocation et la
caricature salle andré maurois laisser
la nive auriez dit bien pire
oui et moi je devrais et moi je vous
réponds oui mais moi je refuse de tout
mais non mais non me dit au nom de la
liberté d'expression ce que je pense je
viens est ce que l valable aussi pour
donner j'ai pas fini les autres
démonstrations j'ai pas fini par se
souhaitait pas répondre sur cette case
non c'est pas ça c'est que c'est hors
sujet donc oui je vous répondrais que
non parce que vous dites la liberté
d'expression ce que je comprends très
bien oui vous avez demandé ma position
sur le conflit israélo-palestinien ce
taux a défini ce que vous bien autant
que d'enchaîner au sérieux parce que il
doit être maintenant c'est moi qui peut
intégrer
mais ce on a fait on a pu inclure à
raison entre les deux le entre les deux
artistes entre givet sur le clip musical
dont elle ait consacré à la laïcité
le propos du clip en question c'est
d'accuser une partie des gens qui se
revendique de la laïcité de vouloir en
réalité uniquement diaboliser les
français de confession musulmane
vous êtes d'accord ou pas avec sa
position moi je pense que dans ce clip
la et dans les paroles qu'il a moi je
pense qu'il va trop loin en particulier
il ya des passages où à mon avis il va
trop loin dans tout ce qui va défendre
mais comment dire le la position n'est
pas d'être contre la laïcité la position
et d'être contre le détournement de la
laïcité
ceci dit lui même a dit depuis que
c'était une provocation inutile
attendait reste quinze secondes parce
que je voudrais aussi écouter et sur le
canal du moulin assad et sandra vous
censurer et sur le problème du symbole
du bataclan oui est-ce que médine est un
terroriste non est-ce que médine est un
islamiste
non donc je vois pas où est le problème
ok au moins c'est clair
benoît du moulin ou alors expliquez-moi
que médine est un islamiste du midi
mehdi m'éclate black m il ya un pire
moment il y en a marre c'est à dire que
on peut se sentant ce que vous dites sur
l'art la distanciation
est ce que vous croyez attendez j'ai
bien du côté de ce que vous avez dit est
ce que vous croyez que délais des petits
jeunes qui n'ont pas forcément le qui
rompt pas eu une éducation et qui vont
passer dix sensation de l'art quand ils
entendent ces paroles oui oui bah oui
y'en a qui arrêtent l'école à 12 ans
puisque vous connaissez la banlieue au
moins si je la connais j'ai vécu un en
banlieue et le gros problème c'est la
déscolarisation dans une association qui
justement aider à scolariser les jeunes
de banlieue j'ai bien vu que le problème
c'était d'avoir de prendre tout premier
degré
vous mettez les phrases comme celle ci
je trouve que c'est criminel je pèse mes
mots je trouve ces criminels de montrer
ce genre de phrases qui sont vraiment
inadmissible et de démontrer aujourd'hui
à des publics qui n'ont pas ce recul et
qu'on dira oui c'est de l'art c'est trop
facile de se retrancher la sous-estimer
les jeunes de banlieue mais c'est pas
grave je pense que vous êtes en train de
sortir du champ de la république sans
vous en rendre compte par les lacets
comme ça je pourrais l'associé sur les
îles d'ailleurs elle même et vous vous
avez fait votre opinion vous retrancher
derrière celle de trop pour moi
l'expression est de droite je la clarée
vous en fait aux aux élus non pour dire
votre opinion ces deux qu'elles soient
en fait estimez-vous grave
en fait vous n'écoutez pas en prime on a
fait trop et complique et on a priori
passer la frontière radio-canada braz et
je rend l'antenne je ne vois pas en quoi
en fait la position de l'association des
victimes du bataclan en fait les fait
sortir du champ républicain
merci et je donne la parole à deux
internautes
même si l'un d'eux va peut-être faire
bondir thomas guénolé d'éveil sur
lefigaro.fr prétendent que l'appel au
meurtre c'est de l'expression artistique
cela permet à la france insoumise
d'excusés toutes les dérives extrémistes
on a bien compris pour vous avoir écouté
thomas des données que ce n'est pas du
tout comme ça que vous avez discuté les
choses absolument et c'est bien c'est
bien pour ça que je me permettais de le
préciser
quant à faut pas charrier encore lui
nous dit c'est évident qu'il faut des
programmes et point d'exclamation au
bono a tort et bien c'est votre point de
vue chers internautes ça tombe bien
c'est aussi le nom et le principe de
cette émission
merci d'avoir accepté ce débat hautement
contradictoires
nous nous retrouvons pour l'émission
demain même heure même endroit ce sera
avec mariam et le nom barbon soir
[Musique]